Traductor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
Revisor: Elisabeth Buffard
En el mundo de J.R.R.,
Gandalf es uno de los 5 brujos
enviado por Valar
para guiar a los habitantes
de la Tierra Media
en sus batallas contra
las fuerzas del mal de Sauron.
El cuerpo de Gandalf era mortal,
sujeto a las leyes físicas
de la Tierra Media,
pero su espíritu era inmortal,
como se ve cuando muere
como Gandalf el Gris
y resucita como Gandalf el Blanco.
Según el guión de Wachowski,
un humano libre solo
tiene que conectarse
y violar el código binario
neón de Matrix
para aprender a
volar un helicóptero
en apenas unos segundos.
Y si eres el Elegido,
o uno de los Elegidos,
ni siquiera necesitas
un helicóptero,
solo un par de
gafas geniales.
Los gatos Cheshire pueden hacer
malabarismos con sus cabezas.
Los iPads son rudimentarios.
Ningún juego de
Qidditch se termina
hasta que la Snitch
dorada es atrapada.
Y la respuesta a la pregunta
más importante de la vida,
del universo,
y a todo,
ciertamente es 42.
Así como en la vida real
los personajes de ficción
operan de forma consistente
dentro de un espectro
de leyes físicas y sociales.
Es lo que hace que
estos mundos complejos
sean creíbles,
comprensibles,
y que valgan la pena explorar.
En la vida real,
la Ley de la Gravedad
mantiene los siete libros
de la serie de "Harry Potter"
en su sitio en millones de estantes
alrededor del mundo.
Sabemos que esto es verdad,
pero también sabemos
que desde que J.K.
escribió las palabras
brujo,
varita mágica,
y "Wingardium Leviosa",
esa Ley de la Gravedad
dejó de existir.
en los billones de páginas
que descansan en
esos sujetalibros.
Los autores de obras
de ciencia ficción y fantasía
crean, literalmente, mundos.
Crean las leyes,
los mapas,
los linajes,
las lenguas,
las culturas,
los universos,
los universos alternativos
dentro de los universos,
y de esos mundos surgen
historias, historias y más historias.
Cuando están bien creados,
los lectores pueden comprender
los mundos de ficción y sus leyes,
así como los personajes
que viven en ellos,
y a veces,
tan bien, o incluso mejor,
que lo que el lector
puede comprender
el mundo externo
fuera del libro.
Pero, ¿cómo?
¿Como los garabatos humanos
plasmados en una página
pueden entrar por nuestros ojos
y mandarle señales
a nuestros cerebros
de modo que decodificamos
lógica y emocionalmente
como narraciones complejas
que nos transportan a luchar,
llorar,
cantar,
y pensar,
que son tan fuertes
que no solo sostienen un mundo
inventado completamente por el autor,
sino que también pueden
cambiar la perspectiva del lector
del mundo real, y
que solo regresa
cuando llegamos a
la última página?
No estoy segura si alguien tiene
la respuesta a esta pregunta,
mas aún, todos los días
se crean mundo ficticios
en nuestras mentes,
en las computadoras,
hasta en las servilletas del
restaurante de la calle de abajo.
La verdad es que la imaginación
y un deseo, figurativamente,
de vivir en tu propio mundo
es todo lo que necesitas
para comenzar a escribir una novela.
No soñé Hogwarts
o la cantina en
la Guerra de las Galaxias,
pero he escrito algunas
novelas de misterio científico
para niños y adolescentes.
He aquí algunas preguntas
y métodos que he usado
para ayudarme a
crear los mundos
en donde se desarrollan
la trama de esos libros.
Comienzo con un lugar básico
y una época.
Ya sea un mundo de fantasía
o en un contexto futurista
del mundo real,
es importante saber dónde estás
y si estás trabajando en el pasado,
el presente,
o el futuro.
Me gusta crear
una línea del tiempo
que muestre cómo el mundo
llegó a formarse.
¿Qué eventos del pasado ayudaron
a darle la forma que tiene hoy?
Luego uso una lluvia de ideas
para responder a estas preguntas
que generan los detalles
de mi mundo ficticio.
¿Qué leyes existen en este lugar?
Lo cubre todo, desde
las leyes de la gravitación
(o su inexistencia)
hasta las leyes de la sociedad,
y el castigo para aquéllos
que violan estas leyes.
¿Qué tipo de gobierno
existe en este mundo?
¿Quién tiene poder
y quién no?
¿En qué cree la gente?
Y, ¿qué es lo que
esta sociedad valora más?
Luego hay que pensar
sobre la vida cotidiana.
¿Cómo es el clima en este mundo?
¿Dónde viven sus habitantes,
o trabajan,
o van a la escuela?
¿Qué comen
y cómo juegan?
¿Cómo trata a sus niños
y ancianos?
¿Cómo se relacionan
con las plantas
y los animales del mundo?
Y, ¿cómo son las plantas
y los animales?
¿Qué tipo de tecnología existe?
¿Medios de transporte?
¿Tipos de comunicación?
¿Acceso a la información?
¡Hay tantas cosas
en las que pensar!
Así que pasa un tiempo
pensando en estas cosas
y la respuestas a esas preguntas,
y andarás por buen camino
en la creación de
tu propio mundo de ficción.
Una vez que conoces tu mundo
así como esperas
que tus lectores también,
deja que tus personajes
ronden libremente
y mira a ver qué pasa.
Y pregúntate:
"¿Cómo este mundo que creastes
le da forma a los individuos
que habitan en él?
¿Y qué tipo de conflictos
puede surgir?"
Responde a estas preguntas
y allí tienes tu historia.
¡Buena suerte,
creador de mundos futuros!